LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance
présente état de santé
[Musique]
à quoi ressemblera l'hôpital dans 5 ou
10 ans une chose est sûre il sera de
plus en plus technologique finalement de
rendre de réaliser des actes les plus
techniques de les faire réaliser par des
robots dans le futur ça sera ça ce qui
travaille le veulent plus lumineux plus
confortable plus à l'écoute des
personnels et surtout des patients on
sait que dans le soin et dans la prise
en charge du patient le confort mais
aussi le confort hôtelier la capacité à
avoir des échanges facilités avec la
famille est extrêmement importante mais
va-t-on y parvenir la rentabilité
sera-t-elle mise en avant au détriment
des bonnes intentions de départ hôpital
du futur évolution ou révolution c'est
le thème de ce numéro d'état de santé
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro des tas de santé
aujourd'hui on va faire un pas de côté
ou plutôt un pas en avant et se projeter
sur ce que devrait être l'hôpital du
futur l'hôpital aujourd'hui on le
connaît on y est tous allait au moins au
moins une fois et on sait qu'il est
souvent très performant souvent à ses
vétusques et très souvent assez saturé
est-ce que l'hôpital de demain il sera
plus moderne c'est sûr plus numérisé
c'est sûr plus robotisé c'est sûr mais
est-ce qu'il sera plus efficace plus
humain et aussi plus accueillants voilà
les défis qui attendent l'hôpital de
demain on va en parler avec quelqu'un
qui connaît très bien l'hôpital public
c'est pour ça qu'on vous a invité
aujourd'hui bonjour professeur Grimaldi
bonjour merci d'être avec nous déjà une
petite question ça peut paraître
anecdotique mais quand on pense hôpital
on pense énormément
de l'hôpital c'est déjà d'être un peu
plus à l'échelle humaine
les études existent sur le sujet en gros
l'optimum parce que vous dites ça serait
pour une gestion pour que entre la
direction administrative et les
soignants on se connaît c'est autour de
entre 400 et 800 likes c'est raisonnable
pour une gestion humaine d'accord mais
il y a eu en tout cas un mouvement
très dans la concentration pour des
raisons vont quasiment industrielles big
is beautiful on a vu restructuration
économie d'échelle et en avant bon donc
il y a eu cette logique là je pense
qu'il y aura un frein professeur il m'a
dit je le disais vous connaissez très
très bien l'hôpital public on regarde
votre portrait
[Musique]
André Grimaldi et professeur émérite de
diabétologie à la Pitié-Salpêtrière
anciennement chef de service
lanceur d'alerte il ne cesse
d'interpeller sur la dégradation de
l'hôpital public à ce titre il a CO
fondé le collectif interhôpitaux fin
2019 depuis 15 ans il réfléchit à ce que
pourrait être l'hôpital du futur il a
écrit de nombreux ouvrages sur l'hôpital
et notre système de santé comme santé
urgence ou manifestent pour la santé
2022 parut cette année aux éditions
Odile Jacob
[Musique]
professeur Grimaldi repartir d'abord de
la situation actuelle que doit rectifier
l'hôpital de demain rapidement
l'hôpital aujourd'hui est assez
gravement malade et il a trois maladies
qui viennent de loin celle qui vient de
plus loin c'est que on n'a pas construit
en France
le service de la médecine de proximité
de ce qu'on appelle le premier recours
le généraliste l'infirmière en ville
avec le pharmacien ce qui fait que
beaucoup des consultations sans
rendez-vous arrivent sur l'hôpital c'est
pas sa mission donc ça embouteille
l'hôpital ça crée des crises notamment
la crise des urgences donc il faut que
l'hôpital aide à construire sa médecine
de ville deuxième chose deuxième maladie
à partir de 2008-2009 on a eu une idée
la médecine devient industrielle grâce
aux progrès technologiques donc le
médecin devient un ingénieur donc
l'hôpital devient une entreprise ce qui
est une part de la vérité mais
complètement faux pour l'épidémie des
maladies chroniques ne parlons pas de la
pandémie complètement faux donc on a eu
une vision étroite et puis troisièmement
à cause de la crise financière puis
économique de 2008 on a mis l'hôpital
public sous contrainte budgétaire et on
a maintenu maintenu Manu c'est-à-dire
que cette rigueur budgétaire se
transformer en austérité et maintenant
en pénurie
première mangue de lit manque manque
manque alors le premier défaut vous avez
cité c'est il faut construire des
hôpitaux de proximité enfin qui puisse
répondre à la médecine de proximité
alors parce que moi justement j'avais
dans l'idée que l'hôpital de demain ce
serait l'hôpital d'abord les urgences et
ensuite des maladies très très graves et
que le reste ça pourrait être traité en
ville c'est complètement faux comme
vision ça c'est pas une bonne vision la
bonne vision c'est de dire il faut aider
la médecine de ville à prendre en charge
le maximum de ce qu'elle peut prendre
qui ne relève ni de la technicité ni
être en échec l'hôpital sa définition
c'est le recours et donc il y a un
besoin d'une coordination entre ville et
hôpital la bonne définition de l'hôpital
c'est il fait ce que ne peut pas faire
la ville il faut que la ville fasse tout
ce qu'elle peut faire mais ça on
l'entend depuis des années dans la
bouche des médecins des grands
professeurs comme vous qui le
revendiquent on ne sait pas très bien
comment ça se décline concrètement
donnez-moi un exemple
prenons une maladie
le bon exemple c'est que ça suppose
qu'en ville on travaille en équipe pour
suivre c'est pas je renouvelle
l'ordonnance
du malade et ce malade il prend pas le
traitement il est mal équilibré on va
aller vers la catastrophe qu'est-ce
qu'on fait il faut travailler avec
l'infirmières et puis si on y arrive pas
il faut peut-être avoir le recours de
spécialistes hospitalier est-ce que la
numérisation du dossier du patient est
aussi un outil intéressant à ce titre là
alors devrait l'être et vous voyez que
depuis des années on a une difficulté
incroyable le dossier médical partagé ça
devient un serpent de mer ça a dépensé
les fortunes pour un résultat qui est
pour le moment
le futur comporte des fluidités de
communication l'hôpital du futur
qu'est-ce qu'il va être quels sont
quelle est sa valeur ajoutée regardez
l'infographie
[Musique]
l'hôpital du futur ce n'est déjà plus de
la science-fiction l'hôpital se
digitalise avec pour modèle le Smart
hospital ou l'hôpital intelligent dans
ce modèle idéal le numérique est au cœur
de la prise en charge du patient
lorsqu'il arrive à l'hôpital il n'a plus
à remplir des tonnes de formulaire grâce
au dossier patient informatisé chaque
service a déjà toutes les données santé
le concernant le parcours patient est
facilité de sa prise de rendez-vous
jusqu'à sa prise en charge hospitalière
et même après grâce à la télémédecine en
somme le Smart hospital doit permettre
une continuité des soins entre l'hôpital
et le lieu de vie du patient pour les
médecins l'intelligence artificielle et
le machine learning sont des aides
précieuses dans l'élaboration du
diagnostic qui pourra être plus précis
et plus fiable
dans certains services notamment en
radiologie l'expérimentation d'outils
d'intelligence artificielle est déjà
éprouvée la notion de Smart hospital se
décline également dans la conception des
bâtiments par exemple dans la gestion et
l'optimisation de la consommation
énergétique ou dans la maîtrise des flux
de passion de personnel l'utilisation de
l'Internet des Objets doit améliorer la
qualité de vie au travail mais
l'apparition de l'hôpital intelligent
pose aussi de nombreuses questions
notamment sur l'utilisation des données
personnelles des patients à la fois sur
le plan légal mais aussi sur le plan
sécuritaire les cyber risques dans les
établissements de santé sont multipliés
[Musique]
professeur et m'a dit on a une idée de
ce que sera le Smart hôpital pour les
hôpitaux est-ce qu'il y aura des
services qui n'existeront plus à
l'hôpital et qui seront complètement
transférés dans la médecine de ville ou
pas du tout si en fonction des progrès
de la médecine l'hôpital but sur le fait
que on n'a pas construit en France
un des services de mes sites de
proximité où on travaille en équipe et
donc le jeune diabétique il dit mais mon
médecin est pas au courant ou il est
seul il est débordé il lui reste
l'hôpital donc effectivement vous avez
raison plein de choses devraient être en
ambulatoire ou bien que en ville si on
construisait la ville et si au fond la
priorité je vous dirai de l'avenir de
l'hôpital c'est la ville ça c'est
intéressant c'est paradoxal mais c'est
intéressant quand on pense à venir de
l'hôpital on pense évidemment
technologie on est maintenant habitué à
l'idée que l'intelligence artificielle
sera notamment au service de la santé et
on pense robotisation c'est intéressant
à ce titre là que qu'on s'arrête sur le
reportage d'Alexia l'éperon qui est allé
au CHU de Toulouse j'imagine que vous le
connaissez l'innovation technologique y
est assez model on va dire on regarde et
on en parle juste après
[Musique]
Toulouse est connu pour ses briques
roses sa Garonne et depuis peu pour son
hôpital il serait le meilleur de France
selon le classement annuel réalisé par
le point
le CHU de Toulouse aurait même une
longueur d'avance sur l'innovation
technologique
voici par exemple à quoi ressemble le
bloc opératoire
et maintenant on va connecter le robot
celui-là nous on a été on a été quand
même très curseur en robotique puisque
ça fait maintenant 11 ans qu'on a ce
robot le chirurgien n'a plus de contact
direct
il opère désormais à distance
à mémoriser sa position
et on peut parfaitement c'est un progrès
aussi c'est un progrès ergonomique pour
le patient bien sûr mais pour les
chirurgiens aussi avoir une position
très physiologique
confort de travail amélioré mais pas
seulement grâce aux manettes et à la
vision 3D le chirurgien a une vue très
précise de ce qu'il fait
résultat l'opération gagne en finesse au
bénéfice du patient
aussi en toute logique la chirurgie
robotique est en pleine expansion dans
les hôpitaux sans pour autant remplacer
les médecins
on va essayer finalement de rendre de
réaliser des actes les plus techniques
de les faire réaliser par des robots
dans le futur ça sera ça ce qui va nous
dégager du temps pour peut-être mieux
s'occuper du moins humanisé
les relations à nos patients qui fait
parfois un peu défaut à notre à notre
époque et je pense qu'il faut vraiment
pas avoir peur de l'hôpital du futur et
de la chirurgie de demain qui va au
contraire gagner un humanité
depuis 15 ans le CHU de Toulouse a
beaucoup investi pour ce moderniser dans
une volonté clairement revendiquée
imaginez l'avenir sauf que ces
investissements ont un coût qui n'a pas
échappé à la Chambre régionale des
contes d'Occitanie dans un rapport de
2020 elle pointe du doigt les nombreux
investissements de l'hôpital qui
auraient entraîné selon elle une
dégradation de la situation financière
la direction du CHU qui nous avons
montré ce rapport affirme avoir depuis
rectifier le tir cependant selon le
directeur si les finances sont améliorés
ce serait justement grâce à l'innovation
et aux nouvelles technologies notre
hôpital est sorti du rouge sur tous les
critères l'innovation a un coût immédiat
parce qu'il faut pouvoir investir dans
des dispositifs d'appui à l'innovation
ou dans des dispositifs innovants
mais il y a un retour de l'innovation
qui est extrêmement important en termes
de qualité en termes de sécurité des
soins et puis en termes de prise en
charge des patients d'autant que
certaines de ces innovations sont peu
coûteuses exemple ce service de
chirurgie orthopédique depuis deux ans
chaque patient est suivi à distance sur
cette interface qui collecte des données
sur son état avant et après son
opération
pour le professeur Reyna c'est un bon
moyen d'améliorer la prise en charge du
patient on leur pose des questions de
leur vie courante est-ce que vous
arrivez à monter sortir de votre voiture
des choses très simples et là je vais
pouvoir évaluer leur évolution de la
douleur par exemple chez ce patient par
rapport aux autres patients de ma
patientèle qui ont eu la même affection
et vis-à-vis aussi des patients qui ont
été opérés par des confrères sur une
même sur une même pathologie un outil
qui peut même aller plus loin
[Musique]
alors professeur Grimaldi c'est très
impressionnant quand même quand on voit
ce chirurgien manipuler ce robot cette
espèce d'extension de lui-même qui va
ensuite triturer le corps du patient
c'est ça l'avenir c'est une partie de la
médecine c'est-à-dire le médecine
technologique l'important c'est que ça
reste des outils techniques au service
du soin
ne le serait-il pas parce que vous savez
que le pilotage automatique c'est un
progrès et puis ça arrive une grande
tempête vous êtes content qu'il y a un
pilote qui sache reprendre les commandes
et là exactement pareil chaque patient
n'est pas comparable à l'autre alors
même sur le plan anatomique
il y a des grandes variabétiques alors
on vise à réduire ça les progrès
scientifiques vise à réduire cela alors
justement comment est-ce qu'on garde le
caractère humain mais même comment
est-ce qu'on augmente si je puis dire on
l'humanisation de la médecine parce que
on a l'impression que avec les cadences
infernales le problème de la saturation
les attentes etc la médecine à l'hôpital
et les de moins en moins humaine le
futur on imagine il faut qu'elle soit à
la fois beaucoup plus robotisés et
beaucoup plus humaine ça se combine
comment si vous avez raison que le
danger c'est que le pro et technique
soit pas au service de l'humanité mais
deviennent une contrainte
donc ça suppose que
chacun est une répartition des tâches
qui correspond à ces compétences
aujourd'hui
non c'est pas le cas du tout aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il y a un glissement de
tâche beaucoup de médecins font ont un
temps qui est pris qui pourrait fait par
des infirmières d'humanisation elle
passe par un grand sujet qui suit des
infirmières en France il manque 100 000
infirmières
1 il faut que des infirmières qui
habitent près des frontières de la
Belgique de l'Allemagne du Luxembourg de
la Suisse ne franchissent pas la
frontière tous les jours parce qu'elle
gagne plus de l'autre côté donc faut
déjà que un salaire reconnu deux il faut
que les conditions de travail soient
améliorées les conditions de travail
c'est pouvoir s'occuper d'un nombre de
patients adaptés en fonction de la
charge de travail de chaque unité et
c'est pas pareil en réanimation en
diabétologie en cardiologie
interventionnelle en chirurgie donc il
faut être définir par unité combien il
faut d'infirmières et aide-soignantes
présentes ensuite il faut travailler en
équipe et en équipe stable il faut pas
que comme aujourd'hui public une semaine
elle commence à 6h la semaine d'après
elle commence à 14h avec un côté un jour
à son service un jour un autre jour
elles sont dans l'autre service dans ce
côté polyvalent c'est pas vrai la
spécialisation et une caractéristique de
tous les métiers de la santé alors pour
finir on va parler quand même de ce que
pourrait être ou de ce que devra être
l'hôpital en tant que tel et en tant que
bâtiment
alexia liperon est allé justement voir
comment à Reims est en train de sortir
de terre un hôpital qui pourrait être
l'hôpital du futur en termes d'accueil
d'aménagement regarder son reportage on
se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
des couloirs étroits avec à peine la
place pour un brancard un hôpital d'un
autre temps
mais dans deux ans voici à quoi il
ressemblera
aujourd'hui le CHU de Reims construit un
hôpital radicalement différent plus
proche des besoins des patients
l'hôpital du futur
car pour l'instant l'hôpital actuel
n'est pas à la hauteur et cela dès
l'entrée
des équipements trop anciens
des couloirs vieillissants et
inhospitaliers où il peut même être
difficile de se croiser
les équipes médicales ont du mal à y
travailler dans de bonnes conditions
en fait on a un hôpital qui est vétusté
donc il y a toute une partie de
l'hôpital qui date des années 1930 une
autre partie qui date des années 70 donc
qui correspondent plus du tout aux
besoins actuels dans la majorité des
services comme ici en néphrologie les
chambres ne sont pas adaptées
c'est pas trop long
un peu il y a 26 lits et donc la plupart
c'est des chambres doubles donc vous
voyez c'est des c'est des c'est des
petites chambres vous avez donc deux
lits assez proches l'un avec l'autre
l'intimité entre les deux listes et
seulement un rideau qui sépare les deux
si jamais on veut sortir le lit derrière
il faut sortir le premier lit pour avant
d'en sortir le le deuxième lit et puis
après il y a un toilette commune avec
juste un toilette et un lavabo et donc
par exemple pour unité comme ça 26 lits
il y a une seule douche
pourtant aujourd'hui les patients
attendent bien plus d'un hôpital alors
derrière ces fenêtres des architectes
essaient de transformer ses attentes en
projet concret à partir de ma quête
de croquis et d'une grande créativité ce
cabinet conçoit à l'hôpital du futur
cela fait donc cinq ans que Geneviève
carigny s'occupe du projet de
reconstruction du CHU de Reims
pour elle tout est à repenser dès
l'entrée de l'hôpital avec un travail
sur la lumière mais aussi l'utilisation
de matériaux naturels et de larges
espaces
l'expérience du patient doit être
travaillée dans chaque détail le confort
et le bien-être qu'on peut l'apaisement
qu'on peut proposer aux patient par une
architecture qui est qui est douce qui
est bienveillante qui est
forcément aide elle ne patient à se
sentir mieux et moins il sera stressé
mieux mieux y vivre et son son
traitement et mieux ce sera ce sera pour
lui
retour au CHU de Reims ou le chantier du
premier bâtiment a déjà bien avancé
depuis janvier 2020
et le chrono où est-ce qu'on en est
aujourd'hui sur le gros œuvre alors
aujourd'hui sur le gros œuvre on est à
20 mm carré de couler sur les 50 km²
prévus d'accord prévu pour 2023 cet
immense bâtiment de 230 millions d'euros
constituent la première phase de la
reconstruction du CHU il a vocation à
regrouper sur un même site la majorité
de l'activité chirurgicale
on peut déjà deviner dans le chantier
les premiers aménagements pensés par les
architectes
sous cette verrière des espaces
d'accueil chaleureux et lumineux avec un
parcours patient et une signalétique
simplifiée derrière ces murs des
couloirs plus larges et accessibles et
surtout
85% de chambre simple plus grande qui
font plus penser à un hôtel qu'à un
hôpital
confort des patients mais aussi
rentabilité un point important qui n'est
pas négligé
l'objectif
entre le matin ou en début d'après-midi
puis sort à la fin de sa prise en charge
qu'elle soit chirurgicale ou bien
médical on a un taux d'ambulatoire qui
ne cesse d'augmenter qui se développera
également dans les années à venir avec
des prises en charge adaptées et
spécifiques pour ces patients le
gouvernement souhaite que 70% des actes
chirurgicaux se fassent en ambulatoire
d'ici 2022 pour atteindre cet objectif
il faudra moderniser comme ici de
nombreux hôpitaux français
[Musique]
professeur et Maldives qui m'a frappé
dans dans leur portage de d'Alexia les
peyrons c'est un moment que quelqu'un
dit il faut que ce soit plus
bienveillant l'hôpital plus lumineux
plus ouvert
plus de vitres puis alors évidemment le
confort presque une hôtellerie c'est ça
c'est ça dont tu as besoin de patient
alors ça fait c'est important pour
guérir pour se sentir mieux
un minimum certain de confort qui est
indispensable la douche une douche pour
plusieurs personnes bon une toilette
pour plusieurs personnes franchement ça
c'est plus possible et au fond l'idée de
la chambre seule en plus avec le covid
on a compris que c'est une règle de
sécurité sanitaire par contre vous avez
raison sur un point je sens que vous
voulez dire c'est à dire qu'il faut que
des lieux de rencontre des lieux
d'échanges tout le monde n'est pas dans
un lit avec une perfusion il faut
pouvoir se rencontrer de ce qui est
déshumanisant c'est des grands couloirs
silencieux
des ports sont pas un bruit et ça arrive
quoi que ce soit je suis seul dans ma
chambre complètement perdu il y a
quelque chose dans le reportage qui nous
invite aussi à concevoir l'hôpital comme
un hôtel je sais qu'il y a des cliniques
privées par exemple qui organisent
l'accueil du patient en terme de service
c'est-à-dire qu'on
prendra en charge la santé du patient
mais on lui proposera aussi un peu de
yoga pourquoi pas un petit soin
esthétique c'était un ça est-ce que pour
vous c'est une dérive complète
complète et caricatural alors je crois
que le covid est passé par là pour
montrer que cette conception d'un
observe commercial y compris
de vendre les chambres seules les gens
doivent payer les chambres seuls ce qui
est une règle élémentaire ça c'est pour
parler dans une de tous les hôpitaux
mais maintenant la Science Publique on
vend les chambres seuls on les chambres
seules alors avec pour ça qu'on
maintient des chambres de lit pour
pouvoir dire est-ce que vous voulez une
chambre seul et on vous la fait payer
même quand il y a que des chambres
seules donc on est dans la dérive
commerciale
si vous voulez une chambre seule vous
payez alors qu'en fait dans le bâtiment
il n'y a que des chambres seules
le meilleur système qu'on avait c'est le
système égalitaire qui permet aux riches
d'être soigné aussi bien que les pauvres
et c'est ça l'hôpital du futur d'abord
été notre invité aujourd'hui dans cet
état de santé on se retrouve bien sûr
très vite sur la chaîne LCP la Chaîne
parlementaire
[Musique]
LCP Assemblée Nationale en partenariat
avec MGEN mutuelle santé prévoyance vous
a présenté état de santé
[Musique]